[Musique]
mais de l'avis site ou kankan est
astucieux belle
le plus sérieux à jouer et le cpie de
vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]
patrick j le démon du riz bon j'ai
chanté toute la nuit dans la forêt c'est
à dire oui en ce moment de faire sa voix
et ça a plus que tu chantais dans la
forêt à torrent c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai oui c'est pour 10,6 à il pleuvait
je t'ai demandé si ça a plu oui oui bien
bien savoir à faire attention
bonjour fabrice ça va oui ça va hein
qu'on joue tu veux qu'on joue ici un jeu
très intéressante oui tu vois regarde
oui on regarde bien il a des verts oui
il ya des vernes à 4 1 2 3 et 4
oui il y en a 3 retourner plus inquiets
comme si on allait servir à boire
ouais oui bon tu as des couteaux aussi
avec toi ah oui j'ai effectivement trois
couteaux alors je te pose un problème où
il faut que tu poses les trois couteaux
en équilibre sur les verts retourné et
que tu puisses ensuite posé l'autre vert
sur les couteaux sans que sa tombe il
sent bien fait essayer de trouver à
temps il faudrait que je fasse alors une
sorte de petit support qui fut saut a
avec les trois couteaux un petit pont
des couteaux et je les appuis sur les
verts voilà alors attends tu verras ton
secours si tu n'as c'est facile pour les
croisés sûrement alors d'accord
oui je vais le croiser je vais y aller
façon de les croiser à petit d'abord
j'essaie et ensuite si je trouve
j'explique comment j'ai fait si je
trouve pas ce que tu vas trouver parce
que je te connais mois atteint ça
devrait être ça tu brûles je brûle et
ben dis-donc bas c'est ça ah ben ça
alors je recommence non je mène vers
dessus voilà pourquoi les alors je vais
expliquer ce que j'ai fait tu n'as
jamais trouvé un jeu aussi vite
avouant je fais ça c'est parce que j'ai
un sens de l' équilibre extraordinaire
et jean maintenant alors attends je
recommence vous prenez que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure deux couteaux
bon vous mettez bien entendu un couteau
en dessous un couteau au dessus puis
vous les appuyer sur les verts après
vous prenez le troisième couteau et
l'astuce consiste
à passer le troisième couteau sous le
couteau du dessous sous le couteau du
dessous et puis ensuite sur le couteau
du dessus voilà souvenez-vous simplement
de ça le troisième couteau sous le
couteau du dessous et sur le couteau du
dessus et après en principe cette date
ni inquiète toujours
ça tient et vous avez réalisé le support
oui c'est pas mal c'est bien là après un
bon début s'est bien fabrice h trouve ça
formidable
à chaque pièce est ambitieux ça me fait
plaisir que cette place est vraiment
gênant bombe alors maintenant tu sors ah
bon d'accord je sors oui là je vais
retrouver jockey et nos amis s'appellent
dès qu'on est près d'accord belle belle
hausse poussive
le voilà ah ben oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comme d'habitude le point commun on
appelle fabrice vous êtes au courant de
ce qu'on fait mais c'est ce que tu dis
oui je l'appelle fabrice oui mais on est
prêt bon d'accord mais voilà voilà voilà
voilà
très bien pas trop difficile un appât
sûr parce que je suis pas dans une forme
extraordinaire
voilà alors fabrice c'est le jus du
point commun tu vas trouver le point
commun entre nous ou plutôt entre les
trois objets que nous représentons oui
alors comme d'habitude
1 qu'est ce tu veux dire je voulais dire
que nos amis font exactement la même
chose chez eux mais exact des juges en
même temps que moi alors je commence
oui voilà je suis très apprécié en
france et en france tout
particulièrement aussi dans le reste du
monde bien sûr mais je suis de la vigne
eux tu aimes ça toi je te connais et on
peut on me plante sur les coteaux
ensoleillés en bourgogne en alsace sur
les bords de la loire tu vois et alors
évidemment ma plus belle période c'est
le mois de septembre où on me garde pour
de grandes fêtes à l'occasion de la
cueillette de mai grappes dorées tu vois
aaa à fabrice les vendanges si tu savais
comme c'est beau un abri faire de belles
j'hésite parce que il faut dire que j'ai
le choix je pourrais te dire que je suis
une table une petite table fine et
délicate ou alors une belle table de
plus une solide et rapide
je pourrais aussi te dire que je suis
une chaise chaises de jardin hs de salon
attia et même pour te montrer que je
n'ai aucune prétention
j'accepte d'être un tabou vraiment pour
cela que ne ferait ch pas voilà jeté
reste choisir ce que tu prêt à tomber je
résume rapidement nous avons la vigne
nous avons la chaise oui maintenant s'il
te plaît pousse-pousse tuer et tuer quoi
toi à moi moi je suis un appareil photo
attention parce qu'il apparaît y
conduisent dans la poche
ah non non je suis un grand un appareil
comme on faisait dans le temps pour
prendre la photo de toute la famille le
jour du mariage alors le photographe se
cachait derrière un voile noir et disait
attention ne bougeront plus le petit
oiseau va sortir
et hop remarque je peux aussi est une
une caméra une grosse comme il y en a
dans les studios de télévision
une caméra qui se déplace en roulant
même toit café de la télévision tu en
avais souvent bon alors le problème
c'est de trouver un point commun
existant entre la vigne la table
fès où le tabouret et l'appareil de
photo le gros appareils de photos où la
caméra
exactement attendez attendez attendez
attendez que je réfléchisse
ah ah je crois j'ai trouvé avec robin il
a trouvé alors tu le pied de vigne le
pied de la table et le pied de
l'appareil de photo ce qui se fait là
aussi bien gérée y est formidable
donc il fallait les amis je vous dis pas
ce que je vais aller préparer de
nouveaux jeux pour fabrice wind à lézat
à tout à leur belle victoire de fabrice
oui la vie elle a dit qu'elle partait
préparer son nouveau jeu on n'a pas
préparé qu'elle a un nouveau jeu et le
mien est le mien je suis maintenant oui
oui c'est un moins bon très bien alors
j'ai un petit problème
ah bon je crois que j'ai oublié son nom
établie de quoi écrire le chercher tu
vas le chercher avant d'écrire sur le
top n'a bien sûr pas ce que lâche et
j'ai un mot j'ai un mot difficile à te
faire cher pousse-pousse eu plus de la
tête que toi je suis distraite
alors alors fabrice là c'est un mot en
dix lettres on dit lei fang il est cuit
alors tu vas essayer de deviner
oui ça commence par quoi eh ben ça
commence par un p ap comme papa voilà
comme ça alors ap oui alors tu fais huit
petits points où il quitterait alors un
habitude de 3 4 7 8 et la dernière c1 t1
télé un thé comme théodule voilà alors
voir comment est ce que c'est un animal
non non est ce que c'est une fleur non
non non pas une fleur parce que c'est
une plante
oui c'est une plante ça c'est important
une plante une plante une plante qui
commence par ap qui finit par un thé
mais ce que c'est une basse et une
crainte qu'il ya dans la forêt bien
entendu oui attendu oui oui
ace a des racines fort oui à derry est
ce que ça sera oui oui jasmin alors tu
permets une petite seconde
oui mais là j'ai bien une idée ça m'en
fous je compte mais ni eux tu veux une
fois la troisième il est peut-être
bah oui ça peut donner un troisième set
ça dd oui alors c'est la troisième
lettre c'est un ace ben oui mais alors
là julien inquiet parce que ça
correspondrait bien ce que j'avais
trouvé mais je cette hausse étant neuf
lettres ne serait pas le pissenlit
berradja et des sites a trouvé à bout
enfin comment est ce que tu écris
puissant les pousses issues baba c'est
facile
j'écris en trois mots comme et son api 2
s e
plus loin le n et après l it et glee
mais c'est très sale ce que tu me dis
que non enfin qu'est ce que tu penses y
réfléchir
regarde comme on écrit pissenlit ben
c'est pas bien tu ne faut qu'un
programme au home à chanaz oui oui abbas
à aubin écoute moi j'en ai acheté alors
j'en ai assez ce monsieur je me fais
toujours attraper moi si j'avais six
mois je lui dois je leur ai donné un
autre nom à lille 1 100 lits il faut pas
il faut pas leur écrire une fois parce
que c'est mal fait ça regarde voilà oui
on y est tu m'as vais me une lettre en
trop voilà voilà comment on n'écrit pas
pissenlit ouais non je suis pas content
de tout leur temps grand-vabre écoute
moi j'aurais dû donner un autre nom car
je sais pas moi même en tout cas ça peut
s'appeler aussi dans de lyon à ou sans
l'aide de chiens ou salade de taux oui
oui parfaitement
ce sont des noms qu'on leur donnait aux
pissenlits autrefois donné ce nom là à
battre est là on les a presque bien à
l'époque salade de top tu dis ça la
salade de tomates salades de chiens et
salades deux chiens un appartement très
bien brice oui je te propose de passer
maintenant chez bell bell
ah bon oui parce qu'elle est prête je
l'aperçois elle m'a dit c'est un nouveau
jeu c'était nouveau jeu qui va bien
intéressé doit intéresser tout le monde
d'ailleurs rien oublié
[Musique]
quelle belle si j'en crois ce que je
viens d'entendre
oui si j'en crois ce que je suis en
train de lire oui c'est un jeu musical
oui alors pas uniquement parce qu'il
faut connaître les notes
oui bien sûr mais tout de même si on est
un peu astucieux et avec un peu
d'imagination on peut très bien se
débrouiller
alors voilà comment cela va se passer je
vais te raconter une histoire
les deux temps en temps je vais
m'interrompre bon et ce sera alors à toi
de compléter ma phrase de trouver le mot
qui manque ou de terminer le mot que je
n'aurais pas fini avec les noms des
notes de la gamme tiens par exemple pour
commencer à l'abandon peut-être avant
avant de commencer serait-il bon oui de
regarder ensemble le nom des notes de la
gamme à eau sur une portée musicale luis
le vit dans la clé de sol
alors là je vous demande est très
attentif mais qui est ainsi les
chirurgies mais nous nous allons
apprendre tous ensemble ces notes est la
clé de sol qui est la clé la plus
utilisée par les musiciens
voilà la clé de sol et rejet lee daniels
est très très joli très serré les dents
appui et voici les notes de la gamme qui
si vous voyez le dos ici leur et le ni
oui le phare le sol là le 6 et le dos et
guide au sis à dos et lui et d'eau grâce
bon alors je je vais prendre des petites
notes que je mettrais ensuite sur josé
du dessus pour jouer là bas je fais quoi
alors mon exemple comment est ce que tu
appelles une histoire très courte
par exemple une espionne nazie un tout
petit un petit 1 avenue de la gamme
ça y est avec deux notes de la gamme je
dirais un petit
vous regardez vous même et puis je vais
vous dire de quoi il s'agit c'est très
bien mais qui a compris que vous
acceptez pas la peine d'avoir peur et de
progresser la terre est d'abord il faut
juste que c'est un petit récit relate ai
dit non je n'ai pas dit à l'afp fabrice
tout le monde avait compris
on s'entraîne de te dire un mot et
spéculent complète
ecoute-moi rupture est en train de
prendre nerfs
1ere année rien n'est rien il ment sont
deux oui alors dans un arrêt et 1 ére
l'a1
et puis ici ça tirait nous fait un air
et feu mais tu es musicien tarif unique
8 s'est amusé à ben moi j'adore ça moi
je suis je suis sûr que de toi et tous
les jeunes amis vous allez beaucoup aimé
ce jeu tiens qu'est ce que je dis non
seulement vous allez l'aimer mais vous
allez nous allons nous allons nous
allons y attend
la voilà la doré ça nous met dans des
voiles à beaucoup de coups de fabrice je
ne veux pas que tu te fatigues trop pour
ce premier essai alors nous allons nous
arrêter parce que je sais pas ce que
j'aime ici sauf que j'ai sauvé il va
être au lieu d'aller faire c'est facile
ça d'aller faire dodo da et voilà
rapport a fait un bon jeu s'appelle
bouillie et puisque nous avons fait de
la musique au propre tête se quitte en
ce sens qu un petit peu de musique en
chantant les quatre amis alosi vous êtes
d'accord
nos amis alors musique s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
pas
le cas l'avis majeur désisté shops des
chances mais comme juni pas de minois
livre honda fait attention les gars ça
n'y aura pas besoin est dit les cats a
mis son heureux d'arisem amis
oui
mais non
[Musique]
vouloir devenir amis